our priority is to have black brown and
women-led businesses on our shelves
there's just not enough right
people told me that this industry was
for white people that
as a black person that
this i was opening myself up for being
arrested that i was never going to be
able to get investment
i was out pitching
i needed a lead investor
whitney beatty recently received an
investment of just under half a million
dollars from a fund launched by jay-z
and a group of cannabis companies who
together are called the parent company
the fund will have an initial investment
of 10 million dollars
you've been pushing the boulder uphill
for so long and finally someone has come
to push it with you
not just someone it's like jay-z has
come to push it
with you of all the people in the world
in an interview with the wall street
journal earlier this year jay-z said he
was motivated by an imbalance in the
marijuana industry
statistics show that while black people
were nearly four times more likely than
whites to be arrested for marijuana
possession
they make up only a small number of
those profiting from the multi-billion
dollar legalized pot industry
it's happening for a number of reasons
and a lot of them are financial
costs about
1 million five two million to open the
dispensary in valley area
i can't go to the sba and ask for a loan
you can't go to bank of america or wells
fargo and ask for a business loan
because this is still federally illegal
and you're stuck in a space where you
need to raise money from vcs or from
angel investors people of color
generally don't have a lot of angel
investors within their networks
biddy hopes the investment from the
jay-z fund will help her meet her goal
of opening a dispensary in the highly
competitive los angeles market by
september so they'll come in and you'll
have signage you'll have kiosks my 401k
does not exist all in the chips are here
if this doesn't happen
i
i don't even want to think about what
happens if this doesn't happen so are we
still looking at um
beginning of august beginning of august
and then a hero comes along
states and municipalities have also
tried to help minority representation in
the industry through social equity
programs that reserve cannabis licenses
for those
groups if we're specifically talking
about
equity and licensing
then
i would describe that program as an
effort to reduce barriers to entering
the legal cannabis market for
communities who have been historically
criminalized by cannabis cat packer
oversees la's cannabis regulations and
licensing a lot of the feedback today
that we receive is just that the process
takes too long
and that the delays are extremely costly
to social equity applicants and this is
the first time i've seen a t-shirt with
jb on it
so
beatty was one of those applicants
she first applied for her dispensary
license in 2019
soon after qualifying she struck a deal
with a venture capital firm i went in
for a meeting in february and i asked
them about their cash viability and they
said we have the money and two weeks
later they said we're closing
and it's over
the legal cannabis industry was much
different when wanda james and her
husband opened their first dispensary in
colorado
we opened up our dispensary in 2009
there were no social equity programs
the cost to open up a dispensary was the
cost of your lease so our first
dispensary including our grow facility
probably cost us in the ballpark of
about two hundred thousand dollars
we wanted to be able to use the
dispensary to talk about
mass incarceration
[Music]
my brother's crime was four ounces of
weed
and that four ounces of weed cost him 10
years of his life in the legal system
james has worked as a consultant helping
several states and municipalities create
cannabis social equity policies if
you're one of the very fortunate people
to be able to get a license hopefully
the social equity program allows for
some type of funding from the state
the reality is is that
while we are
dispersing six million dollars amongst
potentially hundreds of different
applicants our applicants are going to
be competing with businesses who alone
have multi-million dollar budget
the issue that we see right now with
social equity across the united states
is we have yet to see any social equity
program work
that's where funds like jay-z's come in
data shows that between 2013 to 2017
only one percent of u.s startup founders
that received venture capital were black
[Music]
the money beatty received has kept her
on track so far
[Music]
but she still needs to finish
construction and purchase inventory like
edibles from la's madame munchy
what are your men's and what are your
minimums um
especially since you're here in la like
i don't think we'll have a problem you
know with whatever order size you're
going to want to start with
we've got full-out demolition going
right now we are in the middle of a full
build of our space that has been covered
completely by this part of the
investment we are moving forward on you
know all cylinders because of this
anytime there is money out there to be
had i encourage all entrepreneurs to
always go after every dollar that's out
there but let's be real of what the real
effectiveness of those funds are
beta needs to raise over 300 thousand
dollars more it's unclear whether she'll
be able to open her doors to start sales
by her projected september launch date
i'm always about my bottom line comes
down to the cash
there's never enough money there's never
enough money i have been waiting for my
license since september 3rd 2019.
i've been losing money for
22 months now
we have a 10 head embroidery machine of
which we just did the hats
there's no room for failure here there
really isn't
we are eight weeks from greatness or
eight weeks from disaster
[Music]
you